[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: You know, there's
a great line by Carl Sagan that
says that understanding
is a kind of ecstasy,
that we are cognitive beings,
we are creatures of mind.
We have natural inquiry
embedded in our bones.
Curiosity defines us.
We are the frontal
lobes of the universe.
But it's also said
that in life, happiness
comes not from finding
the answers but in seeking
better questions.
And so in the age of
the internet, where
any query, where any piece of
data, knowledge, or insight
is a Google search away,
you come to wonder,
are we living in a world
where wonder is expressed more
intensely, because any time
I wonder about something,
I can look up the answer?
Or is the immediacy with
which the answer is available
actually dulling us into
a state where we rarely
experience the
rapture of discovery,
the rapture of the search?
Not just the destination,
but the journey expressed
as the labor, the
search, the curiosity
seeking to satiate itself.
And so it makes you
wonder, will this simply
open up new vistas,
new questions
we haven't thought of yet?
Are we offloading the simple
questions to the noosphere
and making room for new things
we haven't even thought of yet?
I mean, I like to think so,
because I am an optimist.
Unlike Socrates, who felt
that the invention of writing
would atrophy our brains because
we wouldn't have to remember
anything if we wrote it
down, so, too, people
worry that today's
technologies are
going to atrophy
part of our brain
and limit what it
means to be human.
But I think it won't.
I think it will literally
offload some functionality
and open up new vistas, just
like every technology that
came before.
So that's what I think.
[MUSIC PLAYING]